[Applause]
turn on that thing you guys turn it on
your applause is like a moist finger in
my belly
button all right she lost an election
and now she's projecting Hillary Clinton
went on The View this week which
immediately raises a serious question
what's the weight capacity for that
stage but you'll never guess what she
talked about her love of gardening the
things she does to stay healthy how much
she adores catching and cooking stray
[Music]
kittens nah it was Donald Trump as
expected but it's like I always tell
Taylor Swift girl you got to move
on seriously Trump doesn't just live in
Hillary's brain he's built a 500 unit
condo with inunit laundry and a rooftop
Lounge Sunny hustin the only member of
The View not vaccinated for canine
distemper
kick things off by asking Hillary what
will happen if Trump is reelected which
is odd because Hillary's an expert on
not getting elected I wonder does she
think it would end our country as we
know it I think it would be the end of
our country as we know it and I don't
say that lightly you know I hated losing
and I especially hated losing to him
because I had seen so many warning
signals during the campaign warning
signals that you were going to lose
well too bad you didn't bother to visit
the States you ended up losing you
potato-shaped wine
bag but would he even be worse
now I think that he'd be even worse now
because he was somewhat
restrained believe it or not in in the
first term by people who he hired
because he thought they would go along
with him and they stood up to him and so
now he is going to if he were ever near
the Oval Office again find people who
have no principles no conscience who are
totally tied you know to his fortunes
literally and therefore would do
whatever he said mhm uhhuh mhm people
who have no principles or conscience is
she talking about her husband or herself
they say you always hate in others
what's true about yourself it's why Brad
Pit won't return my
calls
but it sounds like she's projecting no
principles check no conscience big big
check fake charity to enrich yourselves
while not rebuilding Haiti big big big
big check so do Dems make some valid
criticisms about Trump maybe sure why
not we get it he could be rude obnoxious
even ruthless even his biggest fans will
admit that in fact some of his biggest
fans cherish that but he doesn't play by
the rules and he still beat Hillary haha
but the real reason Dems hate Trump is
that he took took their own Playbook and
ran with it never apologize the enemy
deserves nothing and make fun of Chris
Christie but Hillary hates Trump the
same way all her Pals hate him he was us
and not them she went on and on and on
and on huh maybe she's the one who left
Coke in the white
house I hope she talks about when she
was Secretary of State you know when I
was Secretary of State I used to talk
about one and done and what I meant by
that is that people would get
legitimately elected mhm and then they
would try to do away with elections and
do away with opposition and do away with
a free press who's done that so that's
what one and done
meant I assumed it means the number of
times Bill did it with
her I
know don't kill the messenger Hillary
but it's funny here's someone from the
Dems talking about doing away with the
opposition as they continue to
investigate and jail anyone in a red hat
and as for doing away with the Free
Press not only do the Dems shut down
legitimate press Outlets that's how they
won in 2020 they imposed the total
blackout on the New York Post for
reporting about Hunter Biden's abandoned
laptop which was not Russian
disinformation they also worked with the
tech industry to silence anyone who
dares share a different opinion on coid
or the elections buty at least she
didn't compare Trump to
Hitler you could see it in countries
where well Hitler was duly elected
that's right right and so all of a
sudden somebody with those Tendencies
though dictatorial authoritarian
Tendencies would be like okay we're
going to shut this down we're gonna
throw these people in jail by the way
Hitler wasn't elected he was appointed
so her grasp of history is as bad as her
grip on reality and
handrails
but yeah don't you hate it when the
people in power use the law against
their enemies can you imagine if
somebody tried to throw a former
president of the United States in jail I
mean who who does that I'd say she's
lost it but that would imply she even
had it to begin with when we've known
this broad is nuts since
1992 maybe the reason Bill cheats is
because Hillary is hung up on Trump this
DED heran has the balls to call
Republicans Nazis take a look around you
old hag Republicans aren't the ones
beating up Jews Republicans aren't
tearing down posters that kidnapped
Israelis it wasn't a republican who just
got censured by Congress for saying from
The River To The Sea so careful Hillary
calling Trump a Nazi might get young
Democrats to vote for
him meanwhile Republicans are standing
unanimously with Israel Democrats aren't
true Hillary condemned Hamas but then
she insults Jews by comparing Trump to
Hitler remember Trump has Jewish
grandkids he's a sta defender of Israel
and proved it by creating the Abraham
Accord wordss which she could never do
he's also against World War III maybe
that's why Democrats are trying so hard
to start it so take your nazzi smear and
shove it where bill hasn't been since
the
1970s well you know my favorite part of
Hillary's gaslighting she's still the
biggest election denier in history
Democrats have spent the past seven
years screaming about the Russians
stealing the election and she feels it
in her wither bones truly that's got to
be a real kick to her
nuts but my hat's off to her she's done
more to expose the crimes of Democrats
than anybody else all she has to do is
keep opening that big fat mouth so no
matter how bad things are now Rejoice
that Hillary will always be the biggest
loser and just as Bill said he did not
have sexual relations with that woman we
can be grateful we never had president
Hillary screwing over the whole country
thanks
Trump
per
[Applause]
he let's welcome tonight's guest if you
desire wealth she'll be good for your
health host of the evening edit on Fox
Business lez
McDonald when his kids call him it's
usually a pocket dial actor writer and
comedian Jamie
lissau he has to leave early tonight to
study for his trig midterm host of The
Guy Benson show Guy
Benson and she weighs 98 lbs 48 without
hair and makeup New York Times
bestselling author boxus contributor C
tip Jamie it's clear that Hillary
Clinton is a miserable women and you
have uh quite an experience making women
miserable I do uh what would make her
happy what is it that she really wants
these days I don't know I was thinking
about my kids my kids do sometimes
pocket di me but I do get some really
good three minute messages of them
talking to their friends that's nice so
that's nice yeah um sometimes when I see
videos of Hillary I start to think back
and I go I feel like we shouldn't have
been as hard on Bill yeah for doing what
he did like I almost feel like look
going back in time and going just one in
turn oh my
god look what you had to deal with
like what does she want why is she even
on this TV show and I feel stupid
because just the other day I was like
there's no possible way that view could
get worse and then they had Hillary on
yeah remember saying that to you and I
now I'm angry I'm angry I don't I hate
the view I think that's well noted on
this show but I what angers me is I
don't like the name of it I don't think
you should be able to call it the view
if there's nothing to look
[Music]
at that may seem kind of mean but
imagine if you went went to a hotel and
you asked for a room of the view and
then you paid extra and then you went
upstairs and you opened the drapes and
like Joy bear was in your window or
something I'm just
[Laughter]
saying I don't like I don't think the
compar I thought the comparison to
Hitler was absolutely in poor taste I
think uh I don't think comparisons like
that are good you know from from that
Satan lady
no I I shouldn't even say that cuz I
know there's like it's like a hop I
remember reading like oh I hate you know
that comparison like it's evil you know
and I I don't think it's fair and that
was written by Satan
yes you know Liz why doesn't she just
admit that she wants a rematch I mean
she lost to Hitler yeah right she's
going to go to her losing to Hitler
exactly well you know I kept looking at
it I thought I don't want I wouldn't
want to be in her brain oh my God you
know this this is quite a grudge that
she's holding you know and what's she
going to do next compare him to the
Ebola virus I mean how far is she going
to go yeah I mean what's next and by the
way what she did right with the the
steel dossier you know all that other
stuff Trump Alpha Bank yeah fake hoaxes
I mean what Biden is doing it just makes
a house of cards look like Disney I mean
when we see what really went on we're
like really and then you know the only
place I mean that she could talk like
that is the view yeah and I don't know
what's the next step after Hitler Satan
as you point out like how far is she
going to go I don't know Guy
Benson welcome to the show
yes speaking of Guy Benson just just to
clarify you just lumped me in with
Hitler and Satan I know have a question
Greg no I
don't I don't have a question here let
me look for one well I'll say this about
Hillary I think we buried the lead here
cuz she was saying you know who else was
duly elected Hitler was this finally
admission that Donald Trump was duly
elected because she called him
illegitimate for years that's true right
so I think that was an interesting
moment from her and I'll just say this
I'm not a big Trump fan never have been
but it brings me such Joy I was not
having a great day and then I watched
her on the screen say I hated losing
especially to him and it just brought
warmth into my
soul it's just amazing to spend all this
time reliving that moment over and over
again because this is we only see it on
TV she must be doing it all day right
it's like you know when you you still
play little league
right like if you it's junior varsity
now oh junior varsity yeah you drop a
pop fly it may bother you for a day or
two but you don't sit at home in the
uniform you know sniffing your
mitt is that a euphemism Greg no it's
not literally sniffing your MIT
MH I lost your Mrs
Romney
cat great show last night she performed
live at the Hard Rock I was there sold
out thank
you thank you I'm glad you brought out
my tour CU I am on tour as many of you
know I'm going to be in Florida this
weekend um but I haven't been to Florida
yet which is why I'm going there and
this is my first tour but I think I
might have some advice based on what
I've learned which is that you can't
keep the tour going for 8 years going to
the same places with the same material
and yet that's what Hillary is
doing I she's been calling Trump Hitler
since what
2015 we're going into the 2024 election
cycle you either got to write some new
or you got to stop the tour
yeah or Orlando's already sold out but
there are tickets to Jacksonville still
available excellent and she won't be
calling anyone Hitler except for Guy
Benson all
right no I will not actually hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else